There is a fascinating audio recording that
has been leaked in which a prominent Republican
is caught saying that Donald Trump is quote,
killing us, meaning killing, not even necessarily
Republicans, but even some Trump eon Republicans
in important local races.
And this is a riveting peak behind the curtain
in the chaos of the Republican party under
Donald Trump, the Texas Republican house speaker,
Dennis Bonnen is on a radio on an audio recording,
rather asking for help.
Ousting members of his own Republican party
in 2020, he's on recording, calling a female
lawmaker vile and saying that Donald Trump
is quote, killing us.
Now, Democrats have filed a lawsuit that accuses
Bonnen of breaking campaign finance laws who
isn't breaking campaign finance laws these
days.
Right, and there is also a state probe into
allegations of corruption.
This meeting was secretly recorded by the
CEO of a group called empowered Texans, which
is a far right group who CEO Michael Quinn
Sullivan said, the reason I recorded it was
to protect myself, which is also a very interesting
detail in all of this, and this is all happening
because Republicans are at risk of losing
control of the Texas house.
As you probably know, if you follow politics,
Texas is a historically conservative state,
although there have been shades of purple
more and more recently, particularly in some
area areas, but regardless, Republicans have
controlled the Texas house for almost two
decades and now Republicans are in a position
where they could lose control of the house
if they lose nine seats to Democrats in 2020
many Republicans are panicking and Bonnen
is blaming Donald Trump.
He says on the recording, with all due respect
to Trump, who I love, he's killing us in urban,
suburban districts.
Now this warrants some thought.
Is it true that Donald Trump is killing them?
The answer is very regional.
It may well be that in Texas, in urban and
suburban districts, Trump is hurting the brand
of Republicans.
That bonding is a part of, in some parts of
the country, it's not that clear, although
increasingly including in North Carolina,
which will a we've already dealt with on today's
show, Trump is certainly not helping.
Ultimately, if Trump destroys the Republican
party as we know it, or at least seriously
hurts it for a decade, it is their fault they
voted for him.
They are choosing this rope to hang themselves
with if ultimately it is what they hang themselves
with, but it's up to us to make it happen,
and I've talked about that already.
There's another thing to point out, Dennis
Bonnen and the contingent in Texas that is
trying to get other Republicans removed from
office.
This is an extreme group of Republicans.
Dennis Bonnen loves Trump, but he claims to
recognize that Donald Trump is hurting them.
What Dennis Bonnen and his cronies are trying
to do is remove what are some of the more
moderate Texas Republicans and replace them
with unhinged Trumpy and lunatics.
He merely recognizes or at least believes
that Donald Trump is hurting their cause to
do that.
We should not mistake this for Bonnen.
Being the moderate bond in is an absolute
maniac.
And in the end we get to the same place as
nationally on this issue.
If we vote, we can do good things.
If we vote nationally in November of 2020,
we can remove Trump.
We have the numbers.
It's a question of how many of those numbers
will turn up at the ballot box.
If Texan Democrats vote, they can potentially
flip Texas blue, which would be an accomplishment
of stunning historic proportions if we don't
vote.
If they, if you Texas Democrats don't vote,
then everything stays the same or potentially
gets even worse.
And in the end, I mean, it's like, you know,
when you have an election with so many different
factors, Russian meddling problems with voting
machines, social media campaigns in echo chambers,
right wing media, perpetuating the feedback
loops, uh, through algorithmic, uh, echo chambers.
All of the stuff we've talked about, it is
really, you know, Hillary not going to Wisconsin
in the last days of the race.
When you have elections that hinge on under
a hundred thousand votes in three States,
it's very hard to say this is the one thing
that decided the results because there are
so many other things that could have changed
them.
The one part that is completely clear is that
if voter turnout wasn't 50%, if the left just
got out and voted in droves, the answer is
none of those little things matter.
None of those medium-sized things matter because
we just have the numbers.
Now, of course, the opposite is true.
If we don't vote and the writers able to invigorate
their base and get out and vote, we don't
stand a chance.
And that's why ultimately you can point to
any point to blame whatever you want for 2016.
Uh, in a pragmatic sense, Hillary, not campaigning
correctly towards the end Russian meddling,
fear of losing status, racist, blame, anything
you want, but know that we can over a week
we can outdo the impact of all of those elements
by increasing voter turnout, which sounds
like it should be easy to do and it never
quite works out.
Unfortunately.